mary j blige took the time to give back
to an inspirational fan in the midst of
her super bowl halftime show
preparations over the weekend yeah mary
j teamed up with good morning america to
surprise a young woman named india sims
who has been partially paralyzed for her
entire life we'll see you tomorrow
i assume you're a fan like the rest of
us yes i am i think her music a lot now
you're you're a fan of hers would you be
surprised to know if i told you that she
is a fan of
[Music]
hi
how are you
you are an amazing woman you do what we
need on this earth inspiration
inspiration to me thank you and i i
thank you for that song because that
song
um
that's what a lot of people need to know
and see like you don't understand like
i used to sing your songs
all the time
you were an inspiration to me
because
your words
i listened to and that song
inspired me
and i thank you thank you sweetie it's
not a song about vanity at all it's a
song about who we are deep inside good
morning gorgeous good morning smart
woman good morning strong woman it was
something i was saying to myself every
morning because i wasn't feeling
beautiful she's using it in the exact
way you wanted it to be heard and used
you are truly a blessing to all of our
lives you give us so much
courage to keep pushing past the things
that try to restrain us you're so
beautiful you are so powerful and we
need you on this earth god needs you on
this earth we need you thank you thank
you